qué tal si como decía se aplica
prácticamente a todo el país son muy
pocos los lugares que no se ven
afectados a partir de este sábado y
hasta el domingo 30 las restricciones
son muy fuertes se suspenden todo tipo
de actividades sociales económicas
educativas recreativas religiosas y
deportivas durante estos días además la
circulación para las personas que no son
esenciales está totalmente restringida
para las cercanías de sus domicilios
entre además las 6 de la mañana y las 18
horas se podrá salir tal vez hacer un
poco de ejercicio en forma individual a
caminar pero por ejemplo las zonas de
juegos en la ciudad de buenos aires-
para los niños en los parques y en las
plazas estarán cerradas aunque estarán
abiertas las plazas y estas
restricciones como decía se mantienen
hasta el domingo 30 luego volvemos hacia
atrás a como estábamos hasta ahora y
durante el primer fin de semana de junio
otra vez se vuelven a imponer estas
restricciones más fuertes a ver si con
esto se logra contener esta fortísima
segunda ola de coronavirus aquí en
argentina natalio ante todo esto le
pregunto entonces a qué dificultades se
van a enfrentar los ciudadanos y el
mismo gobierno
hacerlas respetar
a ver con un record de 35 mil un poco
más de 35 mil casos reportados a ser
casi 500 muertes en forma sostenida a
todos los días durante la última semana
una duda de los especialistas es si son
suficientes si van a alcanzar para
frenar esta segunda ola tan solo nueve
días algunos sugerían que deberían ser
14 eso por un lado por el otro después
de un 2020 con restricciones muy duras
con una cuarentena muy larga y muy
estricta resta ver si aún en estos nueve
días la ciudadanía va a estar en
condiciones de cumplir estas
restricciones o si para las autoridades
va a ser difícil lograr que haya
acatamiento ya se anunció desde el
gobierno nacional desde los gobiernos
provinciales y de la ciudad de buenos
aires- que habrá un férreo control pero
la pregunta es será suficiente pues ya
lo veremos natalio por supuesto vamos a
estar muy pendientes a lo que ocurre en
argentina con esta cuarentena de nueve
días en casi todo el territorio nacional
como usted bien lo estaba diciendo por
cuenta de esta pandemia de kobe 19 que
todos los países sobre todo de américa
del sur estamos sufriendo natalio
gracias como siempre por su reporte y
por información desde la capital
argentina buenos aires